yeah let's party hit it boys
[Music]
[Applause]
as you make your own Fourth of July
Memories We are going to take a look
back at some of the most memorable 4th
of July memories that have gone viral in
recent years
oh no
bigger Bagel Bagels here put in Reverse
here
[Applause]
that had to be intentional there's no
way like maybe not I don't know why you
would subject yourself to that otherwise
but that
well I'm glad everyone's okay all right
next one
[Music]
[Applause]
like blows up the whole neighborhood
I believe it in in that I don't think
this is a fake or something like that
fake fake fake news when I was a kid I
would usually just go to fireworks at
the beach you know a little Jersey Shore
Beach town that we would go to so I
didn't do them myself usually but I did
some years ago I was at Jeremy boring's
childhood home and we decided we were
going to set off fireworks and maybe we
had a couple coca-colas we're smoking
stogies and we started to light the the
fireworks with our the end of our cigars
and so I do get that people do stupid
stuff in at home fireworks displays that
would be probably one of the stupidest
things I've seen anyone do okay next one
but these are just all fireworks videos
oh Jesus
blood Jesus
whoa whoa that was awesome that was
awesome wow
oh
God
it's going down
what's so interesting about that video
is no the video itself is kind of funny
but the commentary tells you something
about human nature which is when the guy
is scared he calls out to our Lord
calls out to God and so help me help me
help me and then the moment that the
danger passes
he just starts laughing and just stops
calling out to our Lord and just gets
kind of profane you know he's like oh sh
do but then whenever he gets scared
again then he also cries out to God
again it tells you a lot about human
nature okay
[Laughter]
that was a real mixing of cultures that
was the Fourth of July and a little bit
a little bit of a more Middle Eastern
kind of experience as well
this country in the world
or as the countries
is that it is that all of them I'm
debating whether or not the the third
guy took the lord's name in vain
oh Jesus Christ he did I mean he was
just sort of yelling it out but I think
there was some sincerity to I'm I am
scared right now so then it wouldn't be
in vain and so just as a
matter of human nature that's the most
interesting one to me they're all really
really funny I mean the one that blows
up the neighborhood I guess there were a
couple of those those were really funny
the one the one at the end in the garage
I guess probably has the funniest
punchline to it this is America you
can't make me choose I Want It All I'm
an American happy Fourth of July see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]